les vins nature ont la cote mais vous
devez avoir pleinement confiance envers
les vignerons qui les fabriquent parce
qu'il ya aucun contrôle effectué sur ces
on les connaît rouge blanc rosé et même
effervescents mais sait-on vraiment ce
que contiennent les vins pas vraiment et
c'est pour cette raison que de plus en
plus de gens se tournent dans les vins
nature
[Musique]
bonsoir tout le monde mais ses déclas
bienvenu merci d'être à notre
dégustation découverte nature
lagence vinicole le vent dans les voiles
propose des ateliers pour découvrir les
vins naturels
fait la nature c'est simple c'est le
raisin est que le réseau donc verveine à
trier vous buvez l'expression du terroir
l'expression du fruit l'expression durer
20 et busi la passion des vignerons
il existe quatre catégories de vins
levac conventionnelle biologique ou
biodynamique et les vins nature dans le
cas du vin conventionnel les vignes
peuvent être arrosés de pesticides et
d'engrais chimiques et des centaines
d'additifs sont autorisés pendant la
vinification
pour le vin biologique pas de pesticides
de synthèse ni engrais chimiques et un
nombre limité d'additifs le vin bio
dynamique va encore plus loin et
n'autorisent que très peu d'additifs
quant aux vins nature il doit en théorie
ne contenir que du jus de raisin c'est
un peu un sursis c'est juste dur est
fait il rien d'autre pas d'artificiers
pas de maquillage
contrairement aux vins biologiques et
biodynamiques qui sont contrôlés et
certifiés aucune réglementation
n'encadre les vins nature alors c'est ça
qui est un peu embêtant actuellement
avec le phénomène des vins nature c'est
un peu du n'importe quoi il ya des
bonnes choses et de moins bonnes choses
mais on ne dit pas tout ne dit pas toute
la vérité
marc andré gagnon est un journaliste
spécialisé dans le vin et créateur du
site 20 québec et pas de définition
officielle
y a pas d'organisme encore qui est qui
légifèrent qui contrôlent donc c'est un
peu quelque chose de très très libre
pour le moment alors un peu tout le
monde peuvent faire ou dire faire du vin
nature comment les ca qu en fait nous
certifie en fait ce que c'est elle qui
choisit d'écrire nature sur les
bouteilles enfin à côté des bouteilles
et se fie à la bonne foi des producteurs
n'y a pas de réglementation autrement
dit 'tiens producteur dit moins mauvais
et nature vous laissez plus bon
l'étiquette nature puis aussi un peu
près 40% ces vélos ne sont même pas au
bio donc c'est pour eux c'est passé pas
très clair
on demande toujours des analyses à nos
vignerons donc pour savoir qu'est ce qui
a exactement dans le vin juste pas
certaine que la saq demande ces analyses
la saq le confirme sur sa page web
consacrée aux vins nature notre
sélection est étiqueté sur la base de la
propre déclaration du producteur
autre inconnue le taux de sulfite un vin
nature ne devrait contenir que très peu
voire pas de sulfites ajoutés
les sulfites joue un rôle essentiel dans
la vinification en éliminant les levures
et bactéries indésirables et en
protégeant le vin contre l'oxydation
pourtant ils ont encore mauvaise
réputation et a jamais été prouvé que
les sulfates était mauvais pour la santé
parce la quantité de sulfite clients
dans le vin est très petit
et santé canada le confirme la
consommation de sulfite ne comporte
aucun risque pour la majorité de la
population
c'est hyper importante de disques et
consommateurs entre d'expliquer c'est
quoi il suffit
que c'est correct qui en est que oui
leur utilisation abusive et ridicule il
y en a pas besoin
[Musique]
dans son bar à vins de gatineau la
sommelière vérone écrivait met de
l'avant les vins nature ce qui m'allume
dans le monde du vin et des vins qui
goûte ce qu'ils goûtent pas ce qu'ils
viennent de l'hygiène il ya des vins
aujourd'hui on a vraiment d'australie en
main du québec y amène chili qui vont
exactement pareil soit s'ennuie à mourir
mais finalement le vin nature ça a quel
goût les gens sont souvent surpris à
quel point ça groupes différents mais en
fait ce qu'ils goûtent c'est le vrai
présent et le vrai vin en fait les vins
nature qu'ont actuellement sur le marché
et on dirait que ils finissent tous par
goûter comme le beaujolais d'une
vingtaine d'années ça goûte le le petit
fruit le jus c'est bon on a pas de pas
mal
les puristes vont dire amassé nature
c'est normal que ça sente la ferme non
non non c'est pas normal alevins dans
les st paul affirme le vin et
saint-brice bien où ils sont tous sur
d'autres choses ne vont pas sentir le
crottin de cheval quand même le sait il
faut pas que ça cheryl quand on dit que
sa puce et ça sent mauvais c'est plein
de défauts c'est des gens qui savent ce
qu'ils font c'est pas du bon vin nature
les défauts ne sont pas la définition
nature parce que j'ai entendu des voix
des sommeliers des serveurs mais
monsieur n'a lancé comme ça que ça goûte
leurs
excuses mais
j'ai passé ma vie à me battre contre
l'arrogance dans le monde depuis on est
tellement fier aujourd'hui on s'est
débarrassé de ça mais si c'est pour le
remplacer par une autre forme
d'arrogance 7,8 le genre
s'y connaît bien c'est ça que ça goûte
cécile terouanne comprend peau
tous les goûts sont dans la nature mais
doit-on payer plus pour un vin naturel
bien fait
pas extraordinaire non quand même
dans les vingt-quatre d'or dont
peut-être un peu cher pour ce qui donne
j'ai un bon tir lui c'est sûr que en bas
de 25 $ c'est difficile à trouver
parce que ben il ya le vrai coût de la
production
la saq et les agences proposent près de
1000 vins nature et les ventes ont
presque doublé en 2021 comment expliquer
un tel engouement alors les vins nature
ça répond à un besoin autrement dit un
besoin d'authenticité un besoin de
vérité besoin de choses le plus naturel
que possible
des millions de de goût des styles de
vins il y en a pour tout le monde y en a
pour tous les goûts qui en a surtout
pour un bon vin différent chaque jour
jusqu'à la fin de nos gens sans
s'ennuyer